The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right.
So 10 more seconds.
OK.
Let's quiet down.
So that is the-- you got the
70% with the right answer.
If people can just yell out
what was wrong with number one.
AUDIENCE: Sig figs.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Sig figs.
And what about numbers
three and four?
What equation was that using?
AUDIENCE: Second order.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Second order.
That's right.
So this is a good
clicker question
for a problem that's going
to be coming up on exam four
and also on the final
exam to a larger degree.
On the final exam we
have equation sheets
that have all the equations
from the whole semester,
and so you need to figure out
and remember which equation
goes with which problem.
It doesn't say, oh, here is
the expression for first order.
Here's the equation
for second order.
You need to look
and remember which
equation goes with which thing.
But in terms of
first order, what's
a way that you can
remember what a first order
equation would be?
What's missing from first order?
Yeah, the concentration
in the material.
So for first order
it's independent
of the original concentration
in the material, which
is why we can use
first order equations
for nuclear chemistry.
Because the rate of decay
of radioactive nuclei
are independent of the
nuclei around them,
so it's a first order process.
So when you think a little
bit about these equations,
you should be able to
identify which equation
goes with which problem.
And so you can identify the type
of first order problems also.
And for the second order
it almost always says,
for this second
order process, which
gives you a nice hint that
that's a second order process.
And then you just have
to identify the equation.
OK.
So today is more kinetics.
So we're in the kinetics unit.
We'll be in the kinetics unit
for the rest of the semester.
It's our last unit.
So today I think is one of
the most important lectures
in terms of the kinetics
unit because we're
talking about
reaction mechanisms,
and that is really an
important part of kinetics.
So investigating
reaction mechanisms.
So if you're going to describe
how a reaction takes place--
often reactions don't
occur in one step.
It's really uncommon for
reactions to occur in one step.
So you want to describe
the different steps.
And you describe those
steps, which are also
called elementary reactions.
So you break down
a complex reaction
into a series of
steps, and then you
try to figure out
if that mechanism,
if those series of steps,
are consistent with the data
that you've collected on
this particular reaction.
And over here I just
show you some steps
in the natural biosynthesis
of a vitamin biotin.
Biotin is important
vitamin for us.
It's also used a
lot in feedstock.
And so people buy a lot of
biotin to put in feed stock,
and so there's a huge
market of biotin.
Now right now it's made
by what is estimated
to be a 13 step organic
synthesis which produces--
that's a lot of steps.
It's really
expensive, and there's
a huge amount of organic waste
associated with making biotin.
And we're talking about in
the tons level of waste.
So researchers have been
trying to figure out
the mechanism by which
nature makes biotin
because that would be a lot
more environmentally friendly.
So when you're
thinking about this,
what you want to say is, OK,
if we write out a mechanism
is it consistent with
the experimental data
and are there fast
and slow steps?
Because if there's a step
that's really slow maybe
you can do something about it.
Maybe if you're
talking about an enzyme
you could re-engineer the enzyme
so it would be a better enzyme.
Maybe natural selection
didn't particularly work.
Maybe the cell doesn't
really need as much biotin
as we do commercially, so there
was no need to make it fast.
But now we have a
need to make it fast,
so maybe we can do some
evolution of this enzyme
and design something
to be better.
So when you're talking
about reaction mechanisms
you want to know what's
fast, what's slow.
And if you want to use
that product for something,
you want to figure out
how you can change things
to have a better
mechanism-- maybe
avoid some really slow steps
so that you can do better.
Today is also World AIDS Day.
And understanding the
mechanism of HIV protease
was really essential
in designing inhibitors
against that enzyme.
And if you inhibit
the enzyme you
stop the development
of the disease.
So this was a very
important thing,
and we have some
pretty good molecules
to treat AIDS right now.
And some of the challenges
have moved on to other things,
like less good health care
in parts of the world where
this has affected.
So I feel like AIDS has kind
of taken a backseat to hearing
about Ebola recently,
but AIDS is still
a very important problem
and one that smart people
like you could address.
So again, understanding
reaction mechanisms
is very, very important.
All right.
So let's go to a simpler
problem and a simpler reaction
mechanism.
We'll go to our
friend over here where
we have two molecules
of NO reacting
with one molecule of O2 going
to two molecules of NO2.
So someone measured
some rates for this
and came up with the
following rate law
where you have a rate
constant, which is just
called k obs for observed.
And we'll talk about that
more in a little bit.
And they discovered it is
second order with respect to NO
and first order
with respect to O2.
So there's a couple
of things right away
that we can ask about this.
One is, what is the overall
order then of this reaction
from this experimental data?
What would that be?
AUDIENCE: Three.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Three.
Again, if some of you missed it.
2 plus 1 is 3.
This is not where you want to
lose your points on the exam.
There's going to be some
tricky significant figures
in the kinetics units.
Save your points to lose there.
Count 2 plus 1 and get 3.
So is one step likely to have
three different things come
together at the same time?
So how likely is it that
all three things are
going to merge in one step?
No, it's not very
likely, so it's no.
But if it did work that way,
what would it be called?
What molecular reaction?
Do you remember?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
if you have three things
it's a termolecular.
So they're rare.
So that's not how this works.
All right.
So let's look at some rate
laws and try to write a rate
law for a reaction.
We're going to take
our overall reaction,
we're going to divide
it to two steps
and write a rate law for
that and see if that's
consistent with the experiment.
So we finally got this up here.
Sorry the handwriting
isn't perfect.
I got here early but
then-- the first time I'm
going to use the
boards a lot today.
Squeegee was gone.
There's always something.
So we're going to break this
reaction down into two steps.
So in the first step we
have our two molecules of NO
coming together to form
an intermediate N2O2.
And this is a reversible step.
So in the second
step of the reaction
we have our O2
molecule coming in,
reacting with our
intermediate and forming
two molecules of NO2.
And so this is
really pretty common
that when you have a
multistep reaction that you
form an intermediate and
your intermediate goes away.
So now we can think about how
we would write the rate law
for this particular mechanism.
So starting up here.
This is being
written as a series
of steps, which were also
called elementary reactions.
And for an elementary reaction
it occurs exactly as written.
That's its definition of an
elementary reaction or a step.
So now we can write the rate
law for the forward direction
of this exactly
as it is written.
So that would be writing--
and these are my little K's
for rate constants.
So we have K1 times the
concentration of NO to the 2.
So we're writing it
exactly as written.
I said that for an
overall reaction
you can't just look
at the stoichiometry.
You have to think
about experiment.
But for an elementary
reaction you can write it just
from the stoichiometry,
and so this
is how we would write it
just from the stoichiometry.
So what would be the
order of that reaction?
Just the forward reaction?
2.
And that makes it a what
kind of molecular reaction?
AUDIENCE: Bimolecular.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Bimolecular.
Bimolecular.
OK.
So let's write out the rate law
for the reverse reaction now.
And again, exactly as written.
So we're going to have K minus
1 times the concentration
of our intermediate N2O2.
And that would be the rate
law for the reverse reaction.
So what would be the order
for this reaction now?
1.
Right.
We only have one thing in here.
And what do you
call an x molecular
when there's one thing?
AUDIENCE: Uni.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Uni.
Unimolecular.
For step two now
you're good at this.
Let's do a clicker question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
Yup.
So we're just going to write
this exactly as written.
It doesn't say it's a
reversible reaction.
So it's K2-- and I'll
put this down here.
K2-- our rate constant
for the second step--
and then times the reactants.
So we have O2 and our
intermediate N2O2.
So what would be the order of
this reaction or this step?
Two?
We have two things in there.
And again, we call
that bimolecular.
So we have uni-, bi-, and ter-
molecular reactions for order
of 1, 2, and 3.
All right.
So we've written this out.
Now what we want to do
is we want to write out
an overall rate law for this.
So we've written
out the rate laws
for all the individual steps.
And we'll put that-- Yeah,
I guess I can put it-- maybe
I'll try to write it down here.
I was going to have
this all organized
but then the boards
weren't cooperating today.
So I'm going to write
the overall rate.
Let me try it here.
And this is for
formation of N2O2.
And we're going to
put a 2 in there,
and I'll explain
that in a minute.
Then our K2-- so we're
just writing this now
from the last step-- times
O2 and our intermediate N2O2.
So the overall
rate of forming NO2
is the 2 because 2
moles are formed.
So as these guys
disappear-- as O2 and N2O2,
our intermediate,
disappear-- and O's
going to form twice
as fast because there
are two of them being formed.
So we put a 2 in there.
And then we just have
a rate order or rate
law for the last step,
K2 O2 intermediate.
So you can always write the
rate for the overall reaction
from that last step.
Although sometimes we'll see
if they're fast and slow steps
you can also write it from
the rate determining step.
But we're not done here
because we have an intermediate
in this expression.
And in a rate law you cannot
have an intermediate in there.
You need to solve for the
rate in terms of your rate
constants, your reactant
concentration, and your product
concentration.
So we need to get rid of this.
We need to solve for this.
So how are we going to do that?
How are we going
to solve for this?
So we want to think
about now, what
is the net rate
for this formation?
How is that intermediate
being formed,
and how is it being consumed
given those steps up here?
So it's only being formed
in the forward direction
of the first step.
And let me just grab this.
So the forward direction of the
first step, which is K1 times
NO to the 2.
And so this is where our
intermediate is formed.
Our intermediate is going
away in two different steps.
So it's going away in the
reverse direction of step one.
So it's decomposing
in that step.
And so it's
decomposing at the rate
of K minus 1 times
its concentration.
The intermediate is also being
consumed in the second step.
It's reacting with oxygen
and being consumed.
So here it decays and
here it is consumed.
And it's being consumed
by the reaction
K2 times the concentration of
O2 times its concentration.
So that's the second step.
So now we just need
to take that equation
and solve for the
intermediate N2O2.
But we don't know
net rate over there.
We have too many
variables right now.
So at this point we have to use
what's known as a steady state
approximation.
So steady state approximation
and pretty much everything--
I'm talking about
reaction mechanisms--
we're going to use the
steady state approximation.
And that is that the rate of
formation of intermediates
equals the rate at
which they go away.
So the net rate is 0.
So we can set this whole
thing now equal to 0.
So steady state
approximation net rate
is 0, or the rate at which
an intermediate forms equals
the rate at which that
intermediate decays.
So I can rearrange
this equation now,
and I'm going to bring
the terms that have
the intermediate to one side.
So I'm going to
put them over here.
So we have the term
at which it decays--
K minus 1 times
our concentration
of our intermediate.
And it had a negative but
I brought it over here
to this side with a 0,
so now it's positive.
And I'm going to bring the same
for the rate law at which it's
consumed over.
So that's K2 times our
intermediate concentration
and our oxygen concentration.
And now on the other
side we'll have
the rate at which the
intermediate is formed,
which is K1 No to the 2.
So this is another way to
express the steady state
approximation.
The rate at which the
intermediate goes away
equals the rate at
which it's formed.
That's the steady state.
There's no sort of flux
in the intermediate.
It's being formed and
going away at equal rates.
So now we can use this to
solve for the intermediate.
Now we're set.
Now we can solve for
the intermediate.
And so let's do that over here.
So I'm going to pull out--
I had a straight line here.
This one's a little crooked.
I used to write a
lot on the board
and used to evaluate professors
by their good handwriting
and my ratings were always--
my overall rating was limited
by my handwriting
to a large degree
and so I stopped
writing on the board.
But now they've got rid
of that as a criteria,
so I can write on
the board again.
So I'm going to pull
out the concentration
of the intermediate-- our N2O2.
and I'll pull it out of
the expression leaving
K minus 1 and K2 times O2.
So I just pulled out
the concentration
of the intermediate over here.
And then we leave the
other side the same.
Our K1 times our NO squared.
So now I can solve
for the concentration
of the intermediate.
N2O2 equals K1 times NO
squared over K minus 1
plus K2 times O2.
Great.
So we've solved for
the concentration
of the intermediate now.
Now we can take this and
bring it back over here
and put that whole
term into this.
And then we'll have a rate
law that is expressed only
in terms of our rate
constants and our reactants
and/or products.
So let's do more on
the PowerPoint here.
So this is what we
just came up with.
So the concentration of
our intermediate K1 times
NO-- one of our reactants
second order-- over K minus 1
plus K2 times the
concentration of oxygen.
Now I'm going to plug that into
this expression, which we just
got from writing the rate law
for the last step using a 2
because we have two molecules
of product being formed.
So we're going to
plug it in there,
and that's going
to give us this.
So we have our 2, we have a
K1 from here, a K2 from here,
we have our oxygen
concentration,
we have our NO overconcentration
second order over K minus 1
plus K2 times
concentration of oxygen.
So that might be the complete
answer to some problems
but here we were given
an experimental rate
law, which was second order
in NO and first order in O2.
That does not match this.
Term has an O2 at the bottom.
This one doesn't have
an O2 at the bottom.
These are not the same.
So that must mean
that the mechanism has
fast and slow steps
and that we need
to reconsider this expression
in terms of fast and slow steps.
So let's go back now and
think about our mechanism.
And so if we come
over here-- let's
say that the first step--
let's bring this down again.
Let's say the
first step is fast.
And we already said
that it was reversible,
but we'll put that down too.
Is fast and reversible.
And step two is slow.
So I'm just going to
propose that these are true,
and then we will recalculate
what the rate law would
be if you have a fast reversible
step followed by a slow step
and see if that agrees
with experiment.
So to do that we
have to consider
what it means if we have a fast
step followed by a slow step.
So let's introduce a term--
very important term-- which
is the rate determining step.
Also known as the
rate limiting step.
So the slow step of a reaction,
if it's truly a very slow step,
is going to govern the
overall rate of the reaction.
So let's think
about this a minute.
So I told you that the
extra problems for exam four
are long.
They're very long.
Sorry about that, but there
were a lot of problems
and I wanted to get you
ready for exam four.
You also have problem
set nine due tomorrow.
So you've got a lot
of problems to do.
So after class today I
feel that many of you
are going to be
really inspired to get
started on those problems.
And you may run out of here.
You might leap over the chair
in front of you and race
out the door.
You may clear the
table on the way out
because you're in a real hurry
to start those extra problems.
You will run to the library
to look for a table,
but all the tables
will already be taken.
How did your classmates
get out of class so fast
to get all of the
tables in the library?
And they're already
finishing problem set nine
and starting on
the extra problems.
So you race back to your
dorm, but all the tables
in the downstairs
of the dorm are also
filled with 5.111 students.
So finally, on the fifth
floor of one of the dorms
you find an empty table,
and then you're really fast.
You got the problems out,
you got your pencils out,
you got your calculator out,
you've got old equation sheets
out, and ready to go.
It's like two seconds.
So it took you 40 minutes
to find a free table
at MIT that didn't already
have a 5.111 student sitting
and doing those extra
problems and problem set nine.
So it was 40 minutes
plus 2 seconds
to actually start
doing the problems.
So the rate determining
or rate limiting step
was finding your table.
40 minutes plus 2 seconds
is pretty much 40 minutes,
and that's what happens in
these reaction mechanisms.
If you have a really
slow step that
governs the overall
rate of the reaction.
Now a lot of you know also
about rate determining steps
because some of you may be
the rate determining step
in your group of friends.
The rate at which you
get to dinner and eat
is determined by you
being ready to go.
Some are in the room
like me, yeah, that's me.
You know who you are.
So I'm saying that
what you gotta
do to not let yourself be that
person-- that rate determining
person, the RDS in your group of
friends-- you need to get sleep
and you need to eat well
and you need to make sure
you got your ATP.
And that means,
of course, to get
enough sleep you gotta start
problems sets early, especially
the extra problems
because they're long.
Rate determining steps.
Very important.
So let's get back
to our example.
And we made a proposal.
We made a proposal
that step two was
going to be rate determining.
That was slow.
We made the proposal that step
one was fast and reversible.
Step two was slow.
So what that's
going to mean then
is that our rate law for the
first step-- that's fast.
That's a big number.
The rate for the
second step is slow.
Rate determining.
So that will mean then that K1
is going to be greater than K2
times O2, so we can drop
out our concentrations here
to think about them.
They're going to be the same.
So what's left?
That means the rate constant for
that reverse step is very fast.
It's a big number.
That's going to be big
compared to K2 times O2.
So now we can go back and
look at our expression
for the intermediate.
And we note that K
minus 1 is in the bottom
as well as K2 times O2 is in
the bottom of the expression.
So if K minus 1 now is really
big compared to K2 times
O2-- again, that's
the fast step; that's
the slow step-- then this term
pretty much doesn't matter
and it can drop out.
Because this is really
small compared to that.
And if we drop out this term
we can rewrite the expression
like this.
The concentration of our
intermediate rate constant K1
NO squared over K minus 1.
And now we can
rearrange this equation,
bringing the concentrations to
one side and our rate constants
to the other side.
So we have our intermediate
N2O2 over NO squared
equals rate constant
K1 over K minus 1.
What does rate constant K1 over
rate constant K minus 1 equal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: It equals
the equilibrium constant K1
for the first step.
So if you have a fast reversible
step followed by a slow step,
the first step is
basically in equilibrium.
We can make that approximation
that it is in equilibrium
and solve it by thinking
about equilibrium expressions.
Fantastic.
We can be back to
equilibrium expressions.
So let's think about
this a little bit more.
Here I have a pretty
picture for you.
So here we have our reactants
forming our intermediates.
The intermediates are also going
back and forming our reactants.
Reactants are forming the
intermediates and then
back again.
Fast reversible.
Every once in a while an
intermediate gets siphoned off
to products, but if this is
a really, really slow step
it doesn't happen very often.
It doesn't really
affect this very much.
And so basically, this
is in equilibrium.
It's like this part
doesn't even really matter.
It doesn't play in.
So when we have a fast
reversible step followed
by a slow step, we can
assume the first step is
in equilibrium and we can
solve for our intermediate
using equilibrium expressions.
So let's do that.
Let's take our equilibrium
expression for the first step
and now plug it in
to our rate law.
So we can substitute
this step now
or we can have rate
constants or we can
have an equilibrium constant.
You can write either.
These are equivalent.
And we can put those
back into this,
which was our original
overall rate that we wrote.
We weren't done though because
we had an intermediate.
So we can plug this now
in for our concentration
of the intermediate.
And so now we get 2 times K1 K2
O2 NO squared over K minus 1.
Or we could just put that with
the big equilibrium constant
and get rid of our
little K1 over K minus 1.
Both of those are equivalent.
And now we can take all of our
K terms and call them K obs.
So K obs is just the
experimental rate constant.
It's the collection of rate
constants that are measured.
And we often-- when
we measure things,
we can't distinguish K1 from K2.
We sometimes try to
do that, and that's
a little more complicated.
But in this case,
all that was given
was an overall K observed.
And this was our experimental
rate law K observed times O2
first order NO second order.
And now we see this expression
agrees with this rate.
So the fact that we
have a good agreement
means that a mechanism with this
fast reversible step followed
by a slow step gives
rise to a rate law that's
consistent with experiment.
It doesn't prove that's
the right mechanism.
It's very hard to prove
mechanisms are right,
but at least it's consistent.
So we can say this is a
good guess, a good proposal,
for our mechanism.
So let's look at
another example.
So in this example
we have NO again.
We have two molecules
of NO, and now we
have Br2 going to two
molecules of NOBr.
And we're told that the
experimental rate is
K obs times NO first
order, Br2 first order
and asked, for this
proposed mechanism,
which would be the
slow step to give rise
to that experimental data?
So the first thing that we would
want to do with all of these
is to write the rate laws
for each individual step.
So for the forward step
we have one molecule
of NO reacting with Br2
with rate constant K2.
So we get rate constant K1 times
the concentration of NO times
the concentration of Br2.
Again, this is a step or
an elementary reaction,
so we write the rate law just
based on the stoichiometry
here.
Now we can do the same
thing for the reverse rate.
So we have K minus 1
times the concentration
of our intermediate.
So in step two our intermediate,
which is formed in step one,
is reacting with the
second molecule NO,
forming our product.
And we can write the
rate for this as well.
K2 times the concentration
of our intermediate, NOBr2,
times the concentration of NO.
So again, these are steps.
They're elementary
reactions so we
can write the rate law
based on the stoichiometry
in that proposed step.
So now we can write
the overall rate law
for the formation of
NOBr, and we can just
write it from the second
step like we did before.
Again, this is an example.
We're forming two
molecules of product
so there's a two in there.
We have K2.
It's basically just this.
K2 times our
intermediate, NOBr2,
times the concentration of NO.
But once again, we're
not done because there
is an intermediate
in the expression
and you can't have an
intermediate in your rate law.
You need to solve for the rate
law in terms of rate constants,
reactants, and products.
So we need to now solve
for our intermediate
in terms of things that are
allowed in the overall rate
law.
And so we want to
think again about what
is the change in concentration
of our intermediate
So we can do the same
thing that we did before?
So the intermediate is being
formed in the first step.
So we have the rate
law for the first step.
K1 times NO times the
concentration of Br2.
The intermediate is also
decaying in the reverse part
of the first step.
So that's minus the reverse
rate minus K minus 1 times
the intermediate here.
And then it's being
consumed in the second step.
So it's going away by the rate
K2 times the concentration
of the intermediate times
the concentration of NO.
So again, this is exactly what
we did with the first example.
We think about the change,
how it's being formed,
and the two different ways
that it's being consumed.
We can again use a steady
state approximation
and set all of that equal to 0.
So let's do that and we'll solve
again for the intermediate.
So on this next slide now-- I
just put those things up there.
This is what you were
just copying down.
If you didn't finish
it's still here.
And here is the steady
state approximation.
So again, the steady
straight approximation
is the net rate of formation
of your intermediate
equals the net rate
of it's going away.
Net rate is 0.
So rearranging then we can
bring the two terms that
involve the decay
or the consumption
of our intermediate on one
side and then set them equal
to the rate at which that
intermediate is formed.
And then, we can pull out our
terms for our intermediate.
So we pull out NoBr2, leaving
K minus 1, leaving K2 and NO,
and set it equal to the
rate law for the first step
in the forward direction.
We can solve for
the intermediate.
Take this, divide
it by this term.
So we have K1 times
NO times Br2 over K
minus 1 plus K2 times NO.
Now we can take this.
We are done solving
for our intermediate.
We have no more
intermediates in there,
so we can now plug this
back in to the expression we
had before.
So we can take this,
plug it in here,
and that gives us
this formation.
So we have 2 times K1, NO times
NO-- NO squared-- Br2 on top,
K minus 1 on the bottom
plus K2 times NO.
Now we were asked,
what are the fast
and what are the slow steps?
So now we want to take
this and think about,
if there's different
fast and slow steps,
is it consistent then
with the experiment?
So first, let's consider
if the first step was slow
and the second step
was fast-- or i.e.,
if we have K2 NO
greater than K minus 1.
And this is a clicker question,
so why don't you tell me how
this then, using this, changes?
OK.
10 seconds.
Let's now think about
why that's true.
This involved doing a couple
of steps in your head.
So if we have a first
step that's slow
and a second step that's
fast, the second step
involves the K2 times
the concentration of NO.
That's the second step.
That's fast.
That's going to be a big
number compared to K minus 1.
So if we look, both
are on the bottom here.
And if this term, K2
NO, is much, much bigger
than K minus 1, then we
can say K minus 1 goes way.
If we get rid of K
minus 1, we can simplify
the expression even more.
We can get rid of our
K2s and we can get rid
of one of our NOs,
which gives us this.
So saying that the
first step is slow
and the second step
is fast gives us
a very different equation.
A lot of things cancel out.
So we can also write
that expression as K
obs times NO times Br2.
And the overall order of
that reaction would be what?
Yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Two.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yes.
So this is what we would get
for a first step that's slow;
second step that's fast.
Now let's consider if
the first step is fast
and the second step is slow.
So if the first step is
fast that means K minus 1,
the rate constant
for the reverse step,
is going to be a lot
bigger than K2 times NO.
And so now we can look
up at this expression
and say, OK, if this is
much bigger than this
then that cancels out.
And then we're left
with this expression,
which I can put down here.
So that leaves us-- we can't
cancel any more at this point.
So that leaves us
with 2 times K1 times
K2-- these-- NO squared
Br2 over K minus 1.
So assuming different things
about how fast and slow
the steps are gives you
very different rate laws.
We can also write that to
make it look a little simpler
as K obs, but you'll note
that the overall order is
very different.
So what's the
overall order here?
Three.
Right.
So let's remind ourselves what
the experimental rate law was.
And it was NO first
order Br2 first order.
So that means that this
one would be consistent.
So the mechanism is likely
to involve a slow first step
and a fast second step.
And so that's how you do
a lot of these problems.
You think about what is
going to change when you have
different fast and slow steps.
One of them will
be more consistent
with the experimental
data and one of them
will not be consistent.
OK Let's do one
more fast example.
Here we have rate law for two
molecules of ozone O3 going
to three molecules of O2.
And ozone has been in
the news a lot recently.
So we want to keep
our ozone layer.
We don't want it to go away.
So we have O3
going to O2 plus O,
and you're forming
an intermediate O.
That intermediate is
reacting with O3, forming
our two molecules of O2.
So let's just write
out what our rate
is for the forward reaction.
So we have K1 times the
concentration of O3.
For the reverse we have K
minus 1 times concentration
of O2 times the concentration
of our intermediate O.
For the next one we have
K2 times our intermediate O
times the concentration of O3.
So now we're told that
there's a fast reversible step
and a slow step.
So the rate will be
determined by the slow step.
So we can write out the
rate of formation of O2
based on the slow
step, which happens
to be the second step, which
is what we've done all along.
So there's not really a
huge change right now.
So the formation-- again,
two molecules of O2
were formed so we have a 2.
We have K2 times
the concentration
of our intermediate O times
the concentration of O3.
But again, O is an
intermediate so we
need to solve for it in
terms of our products
reactants of rate constants.
But now we're told something
about fast and slow steps
right up front.
And so if we have a
fast reversible step
followed by a slow
step, how can we
solve for our concentration
of our intermediate
in a simpler way than
we've been doing?
What do we use?
Or what can we use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We can use
the equilibrium expression.
So we can put that in.
We can say our equilibrium
expression products
over reactants equals
little K1 over K minus 1,
or equilibrium constant K1.
Solve for O and get either
big equilibrium constant K1
or our little rate
constant K1 over K minus 1,
and we have O3 over O2 here.
So this was a lot simpler
than doing all of that.
So again, if you have a fast
reversible step followed
by a slow step you can
solve for the concentration
of your intermediate using an
equilibrium expression which
you all know how to write.
So that makes your life easier.
Then we can substitute
that back in
and we are able
to put this back.
And we'll solve it for O
and we'll plug in our K1
over K minus 1.
O3.
We had an O3.
So that's squared over O2.
Or we could write that in
terms of K obs O3 concentration
to the 2 over O2.
So let's end with some
fun, thinking about what
we would observe here.
First, the order
and then what would
happen if we double things.
So what is the order
with respect to O3?
You can yell that out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yup.
What is the order for O2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Oh, sorry.
I had something here.
Double this what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: The rate.
Well, four times.
Order here.
Some people yelled it out.
Oh, no.
Oh, man.
It's a clicker question.
I forgot about that.
Don't listen.
But luckily, everyone yelled
out different answers.
All right.
10 more seconds.
OK.
Yup.
So it's minus 1.
And so if you double
it, it will half.
And then finally, the overall
order would be 1 because again,
the overall order is the sum.
So 2 minus 1 is 1.
And last clicker question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
I know you're really in a hurry
to do those extra problems
for exam four.
I'm the rate determining step.
I am with my clicker question.
I admit it.
AUDIENCE: Yay.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right.
All right.
See you Wednesday.
Remember, final
clicker competition
of the year before the finals.